what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video i'm going to do everything i
can to turn you guys into an expert on
the character of michael morbius from
marvel comics yes morbius the living
vampire so morbius was first created by
roy thomas and gil kane and first
appeared in amazing spider-man number
101 in 1971 now here's the funny thing
about this there was an interview that
was done actually last year in november
of 2020 with steve biscotti and i hope
i'm pronouncing his name correctly
but steve had actually talked to roy
thomas about the idea of the movie that
was coming out different things like
that and of course as usually happens in
those interviews roy thomas offered a
little bit of history there in terms of
the creation of morbius and what he
stated here is that for a lot of his
life roy thomas really enjoyed the old
monster stuff old monster movies things
like that dracula played by christopher
lee and so on but one of the things that
he really enjoyed was an old black and
white film that came out around 1957
called the vampire now unlike
traditional stories that dealt with
dracula this was a guy who just had to
consume human blood in order to survive
so he wasn't really called dracula per
se but he kind of fit the mold of what
you would expect from a vampire but this
concept was rolled over into the
character of michael morbius who of
course roy thomas only wrote for a
couple of issues now in spider-man 101
and 102 the way this worked is this
actually came hot off the heels of a
story where spider-man had tried to cure
himself of being spider-man and ended up
growing six arms in the process
or i guess growing four additional arms
so he had six in total and the idea was
to try to find some way to bring this to
an end now during that point in time roy
thomas kind of segued into the nature of
morbius by basically having peter parker
just kind of remove himself from his
involvement with like gwen stacy and jay
jonah jameson and all those guys and he
actually hit up kurt connors the lizard
to basically find a place where he could
lay low of course he was given kirk
hunter's house in the southamptons now
one of the things that you will probably
notice over the course of the coming
months with regards to the morbius film
is that you will likely end up hearing
people talk about things like if the
lizard does appear in like spider-man 3
that you might see references to michael
morbius with regards to kirk connors
himself the reason why is because if
that's the case the history of kirk
connors and and michael morbius are
actually very very important the
motivation behind this was the fact that
with michael morbius himself as far as
his story went we weren't given an
origin story in his first appearance
instead all that really happened is that
he was just kind of a guy who sort of
looked like a looked like a bat to a
degree and he was essentially on a ship
now of course this basically led to the
sailors trying to get rid of him he
jumped aboard they thought he drowned
and so when they went to sleep that
night michael morbius came back looking
the way you normally expect to see him
right very very pale the vampire type
appearance and actually fed on those
guys now one of the things that roy
thomas did here which was genius in
terms of how he handled morbius is that
roy thomas was very very good when it
came to character development more so
than that creating circumstances that
would make you very sympathetic to the
characters and so once michael morbius
had feasted on the sailors there was a
lot of regret there in terms of what he
did it wasn't just like oh man i finally
got a full belly cool let's go find the
next folks instead he hated doing that
so in a lot of ways it mirrored the
dichotomy between like bruce banner and
the incredible hulk right the fact that
banner hated being the hulk hulk hated
banner it was very similar to this of
course it wasn't really a multiple
personality disorder kind of thing with
michael morbius but the fact that he had
to basically kill people in order to
live was something he absolutely
despised about himself and so what ends
up happening here is that you end up
having michael morbius who actually
finds the place where spider-man is is
crashing at that house and then
basically goes in there right at the
moment when he's about to feast on
spider-man conor shows up and then a
kind of fight breaks out between kirk
connors and morbius which of course
happens in uh amazing spider-man number
102. now in that particular story and
the reason why things were so important
when it came to the lizard is because
there comes a point when during the
conflict michael morbius actually bites
kirk connors and when that happens it
actually transforms him or at least
partially back into kirk connors himself
and so the indication there is that
whatever is in the blood of michael
morbius would actually have the ability
to basically cure kirk connors now that
was always a big focus point when it
came to the lizard the idea of finding a
way to turn kirk connors back into his
normal self because remember the whole
motivation of him becoming the lizard in
the first place was trying to find a way
to regrow his missing arm of course with
peter parker having six arms now
whatever was in morbius's blood that
could presumably cure kirk connors could
also cure him and so what it actually
turned into instead of some kind of
traditional story where you saw morbius
basically escaping spider-man and kirk
connors and then going on some kind of a
killing spree or something like that he
was actually just trying to avoid them
he was trying to avoid being caught by
spider-man and and conor's now it wasn't
as though they were going to like you
know kill him and then dissect him or
anything like that what they were
actually looking for was a blood sample
of course morbius wouldn't necessarily
let them have that by the time he got to
the end of issue number 102 this kind of
fight that had taken place between
morbius and spider-man the fact that
moribus was able to hold his own against
both spider-man and kirk connors was one
an indication to fans this guy is pretty
tough and two spider-man ultimately got
his hands on the serum and then
basically cured himself but the biggest
thing that was kind of interesting here
and the reason why roy thomas had stated
that he always wanted to write more of
michael morbius is because at this point
in time in the 1970s in comics we've
talked about this before it's not like
it is now marvel can make a story right
now and then given reaction on social
media and probably within a few weeks
they would know whether or not it was
well received back then you had to go
through a combination of sales and
letters pages so it could take a couple
months before you actually knew whether
or not a character was interesting and
so while marvel didn't necessarily bring
michael morbius directly back into the
spider-man comics what they did is they
rolled him into marvel team-up of course
we'll talk about that here in a second
but as to the origin of michael morbius
the idea here is that he was basically
this just kind of genius scientist right
he had achieved the nobel prize and so
on but he was struggling with a
degenerative illness right an illness
that was quite literally breaking down
his blood cells and so in an effort to
find a way to essentially cure himself
he started meddling with vampire bats
different things like that and actually
tried an experiment that essentially
used electricity to create blood cells
something that had never truly been
tried before the biggest issue with this
is that he and his friend nicos just
never really had time to actually work
on the process right they never really
perfected it anything like that the
whole thing was really based on
desperation and so where the initial
experiment was undertaken and there
seemed to be no real immediate change
regarding morbius what this did is it
actually led to him one believing that
the lights were exceedingly bright so of
course he was kind of put in a in a
deprivation cell and then two once his
friend came back the next morning he was
immediately attacked by morbius now
that's one of the things that again roy
thomas focused on here is that where
nicos was basically killed by morbius it
was immediately regret he was basically
overtaken by urge as opposed to actually
trying to kill nicos himself right it
wasn't really his intention there the
other part of this is that martine had
basically been there of course being the
love interest of michael morbius and so
in realizing he had killed nicos he
effectively took off in the hopes that
he wouldn't come back and kill uh kill
martine instead and so the result of
this is that he just kind of left her on
her own and then of course jumping into
the water and just kind of being
overwhelmed by thirst had come across
those sailors and that basically led
into him encountering spider-man in
issue number 101. now where roy thomas's
work on the original presentation of
morbius was important insofar as it
crafts the backstory of the character
and gave us an idea of what he was about
the marvel team-up stories by jerry
conway in issues three through four were
probably the most important stories
dealing with michael morbius and the
reason why is because there were a
couple things that happened here the
first is that we got this kind of
i guess presentation of michael morbius
in so far it's how he compares to other
people that are out there so a really
good example of this is you basically
ended up learning that when martine had
gone through and looked through all the
documentation that michael morby has had
following him leaving her behind on the
boat jerry conway did a little more
explanation as far as the details of the
experiment he had underwent that where
roy thomas had kind of skimmed over it
and just chalked it up to an experiment
gone wrong that jerry conway had
actually established the attempt of
michael morbius was to create an enzyme
that would basically create more cells
and essentially rid him of this
degenerative blood illness of course it
went awry he became michael morbius
following that martine discovered that
michael morbius and reed richards of the
fantastic four had been in contact which
led her to meet with the fantastic fork
during that discussion johnny storm had
recalled a conversation he'd had with
spider-man where spider-man said that he
faced off against a guy by the name of
morbius another thing you end up
learning is that morbius's former
colleague was a guy named dr jorgensen
and so this was basically a scenario
where jerry conway was building up to
this idea that because michael morbius
needed to cure himself he was going
after his former colleague who would
basically develop a serum to cure
michael morbius of what we could call
his vampirism and so that laid the
groundwork for the unified direction of
where spider-man and uh and human torch
were both meeting up at but then you
also end up learning that jorgensen was
actually a colleague a professor charles
xavier of the x-men and so because
morbius had gone after uh you know
xavier's former colleague xavier sent
the x-men to basically try to find a way
to stop uh michael morbius and so this
basically led to morbius being exposed
through various conflicts to again
spider-man as well as encountering
johnny storm and then meeting the x-men
and while i wouldn't say he overpowered
every single person jerry conway wrote
it in such a way to where michael
morbius was able to survive an encounter
with pretty much all of them and so
while it doesn't seem like the most
impressive thing ever for a character
who had been introduced about six months
beforehand that's pretty wild right
normally you don't see that normally you
don't see a character at least in the
1970s anyway that's introduced and then
within a matter of months overpowers
several superhero teams it doesn't
usually work that way but the important
thing here is it proved to be very
popular for the character of michael
morbius fans latched on they loved the
idea of course the reason why it was
written in marvel team up as opposed to
amazing spider-man was because marvel
didn't want to risk it right marvel
didn't want to take a story that might
not do well when in turn they could just
build on the spider-man mythos and just
kind of go in a little more of the
direction they'd been going in and
ensure strong sales right so it's just
one of those things they just didn't
want to take the risk on potentially
losing money on what was in effect a
cash cow
and so the marvel team up stories again
because they were so popular we started
to see a whole lot more of michael
morbius but the second reason why issues
three through four of marvel team up
were so important is because they
introduced the idea that if michael
morbius bites somebody they can become a
vampire which really brought him more in
line in traditional vampire themes now i
don't really have any recollection or i
don't have any any information to
indicate whether or not roy thomas was
on board with that if it kind of pissed
him off because he didn't really want
michael morbius to be just a vampire as
we knew but regardless of how you slice
it that proved to be a pretty cool
concept now depending on who you talk to
some people will say this is when
michael morbius's stories got a little
wonky and and there's room to make that
argument the reason why is because what
marvel ended up doing following the
marvel team up stories is they actually
rolled him over into a series that was
referred to as adventure into fear now
adventure into fear was a comic book
line that ran between 1970 and 1975 if
anything it initially started out for
the first nine issues as basically
reprints of monster-based stories that
marvel had been writing before marvel
became like a publisher of superheroes
so really during the days when marvel
was known as atlas comics but like
journey into mystery tales to astonish
strange tales a lot of those old monster
type comics those are basically
reprinted in the first line issues with
issue number 10 adventure into fear
basically became a man-thing story of
course man thing being a guardian for
the portal to the multiverse in the
florida everglades and then with issue
number 20 running until issue number 31
it became stories focusing on michael
morbius now the reason why i say it was
a little bit wonky is because by and
large the only thing that really came
out of it that was significant was that
martine was basically bitten and turned
into a vampire but you had some pretty
wild stuff right it turned to what was
essentially an interdimensional story
where you had a guy by the name of
reverend damond who is basically the
leader of a group called the caretakers
of arcturus which was really arcturus iv
but essentially they were a race of
genetic specialists that belonged or at
least were involved in a race called the
fortiscumens some of you guys may recall
that we talked about them before they
were basically a race that was contacted
by the beyonders and were essentially
responsible for creating humanity and
pretty much all the alien races that
exist in mobile comics of course that's
old hat and none of that really applies
anymore at the time it was relevant but
by and large what you basically saw was
michael morbius and martine and then
eventually blade teaming up to basically
fight uh reverend damon and then of
course they ended up coming out on top
and the day was essentially saved i
wouldn't say that story is significant i
wouldn't i would say that if you could
kind of ignore it regarding the entire
history of michael morbius and aside
from the fact that he encountered blade
that blade initially wanted to kill him
and then the two of them realized that
basically michael morbius's situation
wasn't so much that he was an actual
vampire so much as a guy who had just
been transformed from an experiment gone
wrong and that martine became a vampire
it's the only real things to take away
from it now between 1975 at the end of
bill matlow and steve gerber's work on
adventure into fear going into peter
parker's spectacular spider-man number
38 you saw a few things going on with
michael morbius one of the coolest
things that you saw take place was
actually him joining the legion of
monsters in reality this was the
precursor to the midnight suns now the
midnight suns wouldn't really become a
thing until the ghost rider comics in
1992 but the legion of monsters was cool
for it was and in fact it was basically
a coming together of like werewolf by
night and like morbius the living
vampire and so on so for the most part
the roster of what would become the
midnight suns all in an attempt to
basically cure themselves or to be cured
of their various illnesses now of course
it didn't really work but marvel i would
say probably didn't quite know what to
do with that concept and so of course
they just ended up disbanding relatively
quickly but following that with marvel
two and one issue number 15 peter
parker's spectacular spider-man issues
seven and eight you saw these different
stories with morbius the living vampire
where he was involved in different
escapades transported to dimension z
different things along those lines but
all that basically came to a head and
peter parker the spectacular spider-man
issue number 38 in 1980 and what you
actually ended up seeing was this story
basically taking place whereby morbius
had essentially been cured of his
vampirism through like a freak lightning
storm now i have to believe because i
can't really find anything to solidify
one way or the other i have to believe
that one of the big motivations behind
this or seemingly the big motivation
behind this is that there didn't seem to
be a lot of interest in morbius the
living vampire or if there was it just
didn't really seem to maybe trending in
the wrong direction at this point i'm
guessing i have no real indication as to
why it was the case there's no
interviews no nothing right it's just
morbius the living vampire essentially
became human what marvel did is they
actually transitioned him over to a
combination of different stories so he
appeared in like savage she-hulk issue
number nine and then 11 through 12. he
was in fantastic four 266 through 268
west coast avengers 5 and six but for
about nine years he was basically
working with woman he was working with
the west coast avengers he was just kind
of there in human form being kind of
bounced around is somewhat of like a
scientific mind to these various
individuals but by 1989 roy thomas had
basically been brought back when he was
writing doctor strange a sorcerer
supreme and so in issue number 10 he
actually ended up returning michael
morbius to being the living vampire now
a lot of this came by way of this guy
named victor who turned out to be the
brother of doctor strange who is an
actual vampire it was a little wonky the
way that it happened
i'm not gonna lie but i would also say
some of you guys may have heard of
victor strange you may know him by a
different name he went by baron blood
for a little while but i would say over
the course of dr strange sorcerer
supreme issues 14 15 17 and 18 in 1990
running up through spider-man issues 13
to 14 in 1991. morbius was just kind of
there and doing a few things the
spider-man stories in particular were
interesting because you actually end up
learning that spider-man tracks down
these beings that are called sub-humans
which are basically people living in the
sewers not that different from the
morlocks and taking victims for their
masters you end up basically learning
that michael morbius is the one leading
these guys and that michael morbius is
taking these victims so he can
essentially feed on them but all this
got really really cool and michael
morbius actually seemed to really find a
place for himself when you went into
morbius the living vampire number one in
1992. now that was kind of a tie-in
series for an existing story involving
this group that was called the nine
basically supernatural beings that were
destined to stop this person named
lilith who is going to release this
demonic being by the name of xerathos
but with these nine individuals coming
together what you basically got was a
story arc that was called the rise of
the midnight suns it was great
[Laughter]
i love the midnight suns absolutely love
those comics back in the day they were
like everything right with comics of the
1990s i don't know if i'm in the
minority i know a lot of people don't
like the midnight suns but essentially
it was like michael morbius and it was
ghostwriter and all these different guys
right like the dark hold redeemers the
night stalkers it was really really cool
it was a great concept the idea behind
it really seemed to fit directly into
the idea of michael morbius in the sense
that as you were going into like the the
early 1990s with stories that were
coming out like x-force and x-men volume
2 and so on and so forth stories had
gotten a lot more dark but they'd also
become a lot more action-packed and
fast-paced and so this basically led to
what was the kind of horror side of
marvel experiencing something akin to a
resurgence the reason why i say this is
that between 1991 and 1993 specifically
when it came to dr strange sorcerer
supreme issue number 53 you actually saw
a point where nightmare took over the
body of doctor strange and morbius had
to free doctor strange of course that
took place in a story called a nightmare
on bleecker street but over the course
of these various stories it was
phenomenal to see that like michael
morbius was finally kind of getting a
place in the realm of marvel comics
finally getting this kind of spot for
himself where he could basically fit in
not only that while i wouldn't say that
he became a hero i'd say he became more
of an anti-hero to a degree where he
promised to basically feed on the blood
of those individuals who committed
crimes who were basically villains and
so in one of the cooler contributions
that he had it was actually morbius who
joined spider-man and a whole bunch of
people to essentially stop carnage
during the events of maximum carnage now
at this point my knowledge on morbius is
a little lacking
i want to say that he had disappeared
for a while i don't remember if that's
entirely true i know he was present
during the events of civil war but
ultimately he ended up joining armor
which was basically the alternate
reality monitoring and operational
response essentially think of it like
shield except they monitor alternate
universes he was part of that
organization for a little while how deep
that went i don't recall off the top of
my head i want to say there was
basically him being involved in like the
marvel zombies story lines which was a
little bit weird he was involved with
bringing back like frank castle when he
was uh well really i guess franken
castle when frank castle the punisher
became like frankenstein-esque more or
less he did lead his own midnight sons
team for a little while but i do recall
that during the events of like spider
island and all that kind of stuff that
there was one point when he had been
working in horizon labs during danslot's
run uh ultimately he was operating as
somebody called number six which was
basically just this guy that kept a
hazmat seat on so nobody would really
know what was going on in reality it was
just kind of dan's slot having him there
there were a few instances where he was
involved in some bigger story lines but
overall the gist of michael morbius was
very much what it always had been which
was trying to find some way to cure
himself of his vampirism but by and
large as far as i'm aware the role of
michael morbius during really going into
like the the mid to late 2000s up until
the modern day is nowhere near what it
used to be right nowhere near as popular
as it used to be it wasn't as intense
you didn't have things like the massacre
of the midnight suns or anything along
those lines you didn't really have
anything on that level instead while i
would say that morbius had largely been
a background character for quite some
time in marvel comics in the sense that
he kind of had his own solo run for a
little while but he never really had the
same level of prominence as like the
x-men or the incredible hulk or like
iron man or somebody like that that even
the role he had under dan's slot seemed
to be far more minimal than any of the
roles that he had had before but again
as it stands right now he still exists
he's still there he's still out doing a
few things here and there but his role
is not nearly as popular as it was so i
do apologize for the latter half of this
my knowledge is a little bit lacking
when it comes to him uh so i guess i
can't make you a full-fledged expert
hopefully it doesn't kill my credibility
but i will say that because of the
history of michael morbius over the
course of marvel comics specifically in
relation to spider-man and a lot of the
characters that he has faced off against
he's one of those legacy characters he's
one of those iconic characters that has
just been around for so long and had so
many adventures in different capacities
in marvel comics he'll never lose
popularity among comic book readers
there will probably never come a time
when no one's ever heard of michael
morbius just because of the role he
plays at least within the comic book
community if you're some soccer mom out
there you'd probably never heard of him
until you saw the trailer for the movie
but beyond that when it comes to comic
book readers he will always hold a role
there so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end again i
do apologize for the latter half i
should know more about morbius than i do
it's just i guess i haven't really
stayed current on him uh but thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace